crack open a cold one
hey let's trailer commentaries for
ant-man and smoking the reefer
no it's ant-man in the wasp I'm Spencer
J gilbert that's Joestar Dan Marauder
again you know what guys we're back
we're talking about the honest trailer
for ant-man and the wasp that you
hopefully just watching if you stick
around and had a few little things that
didn't make it into the final cut so
skip forward to that but in the meantime
let's talk about ant-man the wasp guys
this to me was a perfectly fine
enjoyable sequel to a perfectly fine
enjoyable first movie yes I like this
first animated movie more than some many
perhaps yep yeah that's where I was my
favorite thing about this movie
specifically was that it was not 50
years worth of serialized sci-fi sure I
think that that is a fair point to make
that your enjoyment of this depends on
how badly you want it to connect to what
you just watched yes 18 other movies
I always just met I think he just meant
that the TARDIS wasn't of it that was
well connected Spencer so I was just
gonna roll with it but yeah I also agree
it is kind of nice to just watch a thing
that's a movie a movie from the
beginning of middle of yeah it doesn't
have like like Michael Douglas doesn't
have to stop to go to a hot tub of fate
to set up Michael Douglas and the hot
baby
I would watch yes thank you l would I
mean I can hear that I can hear it now
the pitter-patter of Marvel shell
comments but it's like this was a this
is a much better comedy than it was a
superhero film as was the first one it's
fine I don't I don't get this I've seen
a lot of vitriol toward this film but
mainly it's just because like I hate
this movie it was nothing special like
well those are two different things
it's fine to be fine I thought that this
was
visually as far as the as far as this
big things getting big little things
that little stuff was was great I think
that the quantum realm not so fond of it
yeah that went from thing that you can
never do and must never attempt to like
here you know a Vegas pretty question
well it's we touched on this a little
bit in the trailer for me it was like
about 30 to 35 minutes of like pretty
solid storytelling advancing the story
of ant-man and the wasp in the quantum
realm enchanted and you know sort of
like really taking here's what he did in
the first movie and here's the sequel to
that movie that was it goes a solid
35-ish minutes of this film and then it
was like an hour of walton goggins
running around in cars I mean around I
felt that that was the weakest element
it's just like I felt like they had
about 35 minutes a good story to tell
they're like we have an hour guys what
we got to do something run it back let's
get an arms dealer in here let's get my
companion to do the drunk history thing
he does again like good to see Randall
Park in a big role yeah it's challenging
though cuz like gee do you do a whole
Ant Man in the wast movie in the quantum
realm and you do like the search for
Janet does it does what they've set up
Ant Man to be work if he's just in a
weird like doctor strange part it's
weird because they've set up if you
think about it his powers make him in
the top upper echelon of superheroes
yeah he could have given Thanos an
aneurysm
or he could have he could have been so
helpful to that but he's stuck he's he
does these kind of street-level
adventures in his in his last two movies
they're they're like heists of
MacGuffins maybe that's by design
because he kind of breaks the plot if
you put them with the other Avengers
like ant-man run into that guy's brain
and make it explode well it's that'd be
a very r-rated movie but with a budget
with Hank in the comics a-and with Hank
in the comics they sort of try to the
angle has always been this guy would be
unstoppable if he wasn't such a sad
drunk look at the precedent so like they
try to do character things and I guess
what they try to do Ascot in the
movies is like he could be unstoppable
if he didn't not care like cuz he
it seems he just like wants to do good
by his daughter and doesn't so I guess
that's what that's what stuff that's the
thin yeah it's sort of narrative line
that's stopping him from just like
murdering everybody all right
well we'll have more to say but we'll
say it while we watch the trailer for
ant-man flurry of activity under steps
[Music]
small as the MCU reaches its darkest
hour killing half of your favorite
heroes in an instant which spoils the
next movie we'll answer the least
important question on everyone's minds
where was Paul Rudd
and man in the was returned to the
franchise that everyone likes but no one
really cares about actual in this
satisfying episode of Marvel season 3
episode a fan while you don't need to
see the first a man to know what's going
on you definitely need to catch up on
Captain America Civil War especially if
you're in the movie I really screwed up
because they didn't tell me when we
started this but I should go see Captain
America so when I read the script for
this I had no idea that began what was
going on you are everyone's dead hand
gestures and older dudes does that just
get worse as you get really yeah can't I
talk with my hands alive yeah but I
think it does it get worse I think it
cuts across age okay now it's definitely
some cultures or big hand time dad's
leveled up a lot as they Scott okay I
think as you get older you have more
things to explain you do more wagging
the finger like you understand what I'm
trying to reach out to you okay I mean
speaking of Doctor Who I mean I watched
five scenes of Matt Smith in the happy
hands club anyways everything comes back
to who that's all I had yeah Michael
Douglas it's a great interview it's with
MTV and I promise I'll watch it next
time it's Peyton Reed has to tell me to
watch it and I'll do it
he's very much like I mean I imagine a
lot of people are just like they treat
these things casually like well I had to
watch the third Captain America to know
what's happening in the second Ant Man
like pass if you're mr. Douglas is aged
he lives in a world or like franchises
were apart from each other you have to
go watch Batman know what's going on
Superman and it's like I have to well
the thing with Marvel 2 now is now that
there's so much like you can specialize
like my mother-in-law only watches
Guardians and Thor nice so we sugar
she's a cop we showed her Infinity Ward
she was just like why would people be
mad at Captain America
yeah yeah that's a commitment well there
you go definitely commitment yeah
anyways we love you mr. Douglas keep
going
you are everyone's dad right now mr.
Douglas and I love you for it
the Judis marvel white boy not named
Chris returns as ant-man the hurom ATO's
the line between every star and just
plain effortless
he'll team up once again with Hank Pym
the guy who invented an end to world
hunger film used it to build fighting
some puzzle uh he's a bad man
if he can grow or shrink food he can
either grow like one large cow we all
eat the big cow or he can take all food
logistics and supply chain problems and
just take you know an entire crop of
fields worth of crops in his pocket you
know two regions that need it when you
think about it he and Thanos could
really have teamed up to solve that
whole world hunger travel you need a
snap to erase half just bring me Hank
Pym and then give Hank Pym a conscience
and then BOOM although I do take a a
umbrage do you realize what kind of
destruction of massive cow could wreak
are you were to grow a cow to that size
a massive bean I would pick your pick a
massive feed this is science Joe science
not magic where I come from they're one
in the same
yeah you just built punching suits what
the hell yeah that's true build a huge
field I love that because they touch on
that and Iron Man to where he's like
we've made Intelli crops and this and
that I'm gonna make a better I'm 16 like
yeah or like yeah I think Tony Stark's
several times over invented like
infinite clean energy sources yes gonna
use it to build shooting suits yeah
wasn't he powering his lab off of these
like yes huge Duracell batteries that
were like plugged in yes I reviewed I
was like how do they get powered it was
like good you did not see the massive
Duracell batteries bug this so obviously
you figured out a huge solution to power
store it's like there goes greenhouse
gas any one of them could've nanotech so
like if a building goes down he can
nanotech it back up in a second there's
really exciting students there's a whole
subtext to my
we won't get into here but that
superheroes are there to maintain the
status quo and not actually improve the
world because that cos change is bad
yeah Marvel Universe there keep things
in place especially the Pym particle
yeah which is only held back by one
man's alcoholism otherwise yeah anyways
keep going till fighting soothes hope
Van Dyne the first female Marvel hero in
a movie title and like the fifth female
Marvel hero playing the series when
rolling her eyes at a goofy male
counterpart the MCU movies only Mexican
character by being the absolute most
Mexican character we should we should
point out that we specifically wrote MC
movies only Mexican character because a
ghost writer in an agency field is which
is a TV show TV show as part of the MCU
yes which is why I said movies yep
movies if you have to if you ask Jeff
lobe it is definitely part of the MCU
yes according to we are we are aware of
Robby Robby Reyes Robby is Robby Reyes
and I think we made some like in the
first day man like the only Latino in
the MCU which we were corrected so he is
the only person playing an actual
mexican-american there are other Latino
Latin text actors and actress but they
are playing green cosmic beings what
we're saying is that we hear you and
we're doing our best
this is really what we're doing
everything we can do we're not perfect
well we try far from it but and so is
Michael Pena for representing twice as
hard and so is Morrissey yeah anyways
keep going or gonna come to the game
okay the last but the other range is
some buyers for you laughs got to get
that land back
we need to regroup and figure out what
happy Sims lab is gone get my lab I want
that loud I'll get the lab Wow Bert's
got the lab I got the lab
as our heroes race to save Michelle
Pfeiffer from 30 years in the quantum
realm a CGI Wonderland made of Doctor
Strange outtakes Easter eggs and I guess
beauty supplies because she came out of
there looking nice but hot on their
tails
30 years just wants to cure her chronic
pain and gets the snut beaten out of her
for trying
that'll teach you not to want pain and
last but definitely least sunny birch a
regular guy with a couple of goons
attends some of mr. crappie restaurant I
guess let's talk about Goggins well the
villains in this movie in general
because like they had a compelling thing
going with ghosts of like she's too
sympathetic it's like she's literally
just trying to save her own life with
this technology that he refuses to share
with anyone else the whole world so
let's get my lab and keep it from these
people and then they did this weird
thing where like Laurence Fishburne was
like helping her but he was a fraud but
then it turned out he wasn't like he was
too good he ended up being good also
fake villain it was the fake-out villain
fake out yeah they double faked out him
as a villain so they were left with no
villains yeah I know like alright we
need a bill we need somebody would it
have been interesting if they had just
done the fake out there's no villains
and everyone gets Janet out together and
it's fine would that have been a
refreshing formula thing or would have
that have been weird and it would have
fallen on its face I guess if they could
have made like a final challenge of
getting Janet out and like that would be
your third act like ending secrets of
like Dormammu in the doctor strange or
something that what I kept expecting was
Walton Goggins who's criminally misused
in every he's a 20-18 baserunner movie
tomb raider and now this one yeah howdy
you
we're 80% there just by casting gun is
he gonna have his Sam Rockwell year I
don't know but speaking of Sam Rockwell
it's like he could have been Justin
Hammer yeah I keep he keeps talking
about my buyers
you know people interested in this lab I
keep expecting him to get off the phone
with Marvel supervillain claw you know
get some him to finally pick up the
phone and he ends up calling Randall
Parks like lower support
is like not the guy running the FBI
investigation but the guy below that who
like works for that guy is in basically
like a step above the anonymous tip line
of the yeah it was like his hook up so I
just got a when you think about what
this guy was putting himself into yes
was a life threatening putting himself
into the middle of a life-threatening
battle between two people with the power
to shrink two quantum dots and beat the
[ __ ] out of people and merge cells apart
yeah and hide entire labs down into an
instant he's a guy with an Escalade and
a dream he's got gold rims basically
anymore his car's gone yeah and he's
still like I'm even after he finds
ghosts who's like phasing through the
walls and kicking people's ass he's like
you know it I still think I can pull
this off I still think I gotta shoot me
that lab get me that lab I'm gonna fight
both of the super-powered factions
where are my faceless goons yeah you see
the American dream Aleut you yeah Sonny
birch you might be the most underrated
but criminally outmatched here's to you
keep it up Goggins anyway so that's my
rant about the bad guy in a man to keep
going violations in my restaurant come
on where's this tech super boss
he's going after Ford the strongest -
people in the MCU with nothing but a
cell phone in a dream oh come on Iron
Fist could beat this guy
I enjoy all the visual and memory you've
come to expect where little things are
in bigand and big things are constantly
belittled me to our finish comparing
sizes creating awesome action scenes
that spit in the face of physics but
according to Marvel you can make science
do anything you just let the word
quantum on it quantum realm quantum
technology quantum anomaly quantum phase
ponton spectrometer and quantum system
quantum energy quanta me
boy come on tangle me into quantum state
quantum healing particles did you guys
just put the word quantum in front of
everything hey stop going at your own
lazy explanations that's our job at
puzzle to what degree to what how much
how much leeway do you give lamp shading
in a movie which for people that don't
know lamp shading is calling out
something in a movie like we pointed it
out so well head shape in this case I
don't really care because like man it's
a man and the marvel science
explanations have never been grounded
during the most science sure it would
bother me more in something like like an
interstellar we're obviously bendy
science and that too but the creator
intention was that like this is real and
you'll take this very seriously yeah so
I think if they had lamb shaded that a
lot or just write wrote things off well
we don't know how any of it really works
after like spending their whole movie
being like this is a very serious
explanation as to why everything in
interstellar works they would have
bothered me there but maybe yeah I mean
in the wasp know the end of the day it's
Paul yeah they make I know since the the
Pym particles are supposed or whatever
it is it's supposed to reduce the space
between atoms I think is the way they
explain it but quantum stuff is smaller
than atoms do you care damn no I just
wonder like I think some I'm not saying
this movie does it but I feel like some
films use lamp shading as a way to just
get away with laziness yeah I think this
is probably like the Marvel punch-up
process if somebody's like they're you
really say this a lot someone's gonna
ding you for it why do you have Paul
Rudd riff about why you say this yeah
we've seen it so much there
yeah problem solved babe angst anyways
keep going moving so enjoy a film that
managed to be funny and compelling with
good action and great effects
that would have blown everyone's mind
less than two years ago
because it doesn't further Marvel's
nineteen movie super pod enough nerds
will treat it like a pesky insect how
many planets do they visit just one a
pass I don't get out of bed for anything
less than the celestial oh good day sir
starring big hero sticks and Smalling
down if you like it then you should've
put a thing on it referendums emo
definitely not Nick Fury for those that
don't know there was a Superbowl ad once
that started Laurence Fishburne doing a
riff on the matrix and this having old
Texan went on to a news show the order
you've gotta know how to do this Super
Bowl F he's like what at what ad he's
like and then they charge the score is
like wait no you would not let him go
for like four minutes
and you're the entertainment reporter my
favorite my favorite part is if you look
behind them he was yes he was the best
part of the KTLA not the place you go
for hard-hitting news but if you've been
hit hard by a by a car helicopter never
leaves the sky I saw the guy crossed the
street he just got creamed by that car
seven hours a day yes
yeah so anyway they pick up that clip if
you don't know just tights and axes
Laurence Fishburne anyways moving on
office park a bug's wife phasing Anthony
Mackie
and Kevin and the buggies that's the
ghost of Bridgers sorry hat yeah I think
[ __ ] mice must dictate a home all the
furniture is both the dad before you did
that also I hope you have a septic tank
because those toilets are not hooked up
to anything it's it's quantum it's what
the quantum yeah yeah I mean everything
in there is just tipping over quantum
sanitation everything's all right what
uh what storing biggie smalls
professor shrink the eighth smartest
genius in the MCU
maybe you 20th now win commando sting
commander just bring back Justin Hammer
you guys faced and Confused Wicked Witch
of the West
big larvas house Gus Van Sant home for
involuntary friends I Dream of Jeannie
pinfinity war quantum downsizing of suck
ass is like what happened to you like
this crazy creepy cat who like wants two
walls and stuff like I like like a ghost
like Baba Yaga John wick and the MCU
confirmed yes
yeah I'll always associate Baba Yaga
with John wick from oh yeah yeah I mean
I know the Baba Yaga is I'm sure
folklore and of itself boogeyman that's
the first I heard of this dog the Baba
Yaga come for you yeah so there you go
uh a delightful little stack of a film a
delightful little snack the NHANES
trailer mm-hmm
tastes great not filling I feel no need
to say anything more about it I
forgotten that we did the trailer
I've already forgotten what we did this
is a piece of honest trailer trivia
though this is officially now the first
time because we're on an off cycle the
first time in the history of honest
trailers that we now have honest
trailers for every single available film
in the MCU just caught up with
Incredible Hulk before and we were
always doing honest trailers for MCU
movies before the next MCU movie ripened
so there was always a new one coming out
that we hadn't done when we were doing
one but now with the loss we've caught
up with we a dog has caught its own tail
we've caught up with the MCU and now we
got nothing till Captain Marvel
what are we gonna do for Captain Mark
yeah we're screwed the old Supergirl
movie I guess Wow well we have something
to do next week and in the meantime just
watch all the MCU honest trailers in a
row it's a lot easier than watching all
the movies 20 of them and you can trace
the evolution of honest trailers
although they're not in order
they're far away out of my first one we
did yeah totally so that'll be weird um
anyways come back next week we've got a
nice thing brewing seasonally
appropriate I'd say I'd say very
seasonally appropriate yeah yeah baby
[Laughter]
[Music]
you